CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, I'd like us to
work on the following problem.
We're going to let F be the
vector field that's defined
by r to the n, times the
quantity x*i plus y*j.
And r in this case is x squared
plus y squared to the 1/2,
as it usually is.
The square root of x
squared plus y squared.
And then I'd like us
to do the following.
Use extended Green's
theorem to show
that F is conservative
for all integers n.
And then find a
potential function.
So there are two parts.
The first part is that you want
to show that F is conservative.
And then once you know
it's conservative,
you can find a
potential function.
So why don't you take a
little while to work on that.
And then when you're feeling
good about your answer,
bring the video back up, and
I'll show you what I did.
OK, welcome back.
So again, what was the
point of this video?
We want to do two things.
We want to work on two problems.
The first is to show
that this vector field F
I've given you is conservative.
And then we want to find
a potential function.
And we want to be
able to show it's
conservative for all integers n.
And what I want to point out is
that for certain integer values
of n, we're going to
run into some problems
with differentiability
at the origin.
OK?
So we're going to try and
deal with all of it at once,
and simultaneously deal
with all of the integers,
by allowing ourselves to
show that F is conservative
even if we don't include
the origin in our region.
OK.
So I want to point out
a few things first.
And the first thing I want to
point out is if we denote F
as we usually do in two
dimensions as [M, N],
then the curl of F is going
to be N sub x minus M sub y.
OK.
I actually calculated
these earlier,
but I want to point out that
M sub y is actually equal to n
times r to the n
minus 2, times x*y.
Let me make sure I
wrote that correctly.
Yes.
But that is also exactly
equal to N sub x.
And so what does that give us?
Since N sub x minus M
sub y is the curl of F,
when we have this vector [M, N],
we know that the curl of F is
equal to 0 by this work.
OK, now if our vector
field was defined
on a simply-connected
region, then that's
enough to show that
F is conservative.
OK?
We just use Green's
theorem right away.
Right?
But the problem is that
we are not necessarily
on a simply-connected
region because we could
have problems at the origin.
And so I'm going
to deal with this
in a slightly different way.
To show that F is conservative,
what do I want to show?
I want to show that
when I take the line
integral F dot dr over any
closed loop that I get 0.
That's ultimately what
I'm trying to show.
So there are fundamentally
two types of curves
that I'm concerned with.
Two closed curves in R^2
that I'm concerned with,
and I'm going to draw a picture
of those two types of curves.
So in R^2, I'm going to have
curves that miss the origin--
some curve like this,
which I'll call C_1.
And then I'm going
to have curves
that go around the origin,
and I'll call this C_2.
OK?
Fundamentally,
there's a difference
between this curve
and this curve,
because this curve contains
the region where F is defined
and differentiable, right?
Every point on the
interior of this curve, F
is defined and differentiable
and therefore, I
can apply regular old
Green's theorem here.
OK?
So I know by Green's theorem,
the integral over the closed
curve C_1 of F dot
dr is equal to 0,
and that's simply because
the curl of F is equal to 0.
Right?
We can immediately
use Green's theorem
because we know that the
integral over this loop C_1
is equal to the integral over
this region of the curl of F.
That's just Green's theorem.
So I can apply
Green's theorem here.
Now the problem here is I
can't apply Green's theorem
because this origin
is a trouble spot.
Right?
I'm not necessarily
differentiable there,
so I have to be a
little more careful.
OK, and so what
I do is I'm going
to explain why, immediately,
I can get the integral over C2
is actually also 0.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm actually
going to draw, hopefully,
a circle that contains C_2.
So I'm going to draw a circle.
It's a lot of
curves, but this is
supposed to look like a circle.
Sorry about that.
It's a little big on the
low side, but it's a circle.
OK.
This is a circle.
And I'm going to call this C_3.
Now, I can tell you right
away that the integral
over the curve C_3 of
F dot dr is equal to 0,
and let me explain why.
OK?
F is a normal vector field
relative to a circle.
Let's look at this again.
It's radial, and that's
why we know this.
F is a radial vector field.
It's really the vector
field [x, y] times a scalar,
depending on the radius.
So if I look at this
picture right here,
then F is going
to-- let me draw it
in color-- F is going
to, at any given point,
be in the radial direction.
But that is exactly normal
to the tangent direction
of this curve.
So this is the
direction F points,
and this is the
direction the tangent
vector points to the curve.
But remember, F dot dr
is the same as F dotted
with the tangent vector ds.
OK?
And so that is why
for this circle,
it's immediately obvious
that F dot dr is equal to 0.
Because at any given
point on this circle,
I'm taking a vector
field, I'm dotting it
with a vector field that's
orthogonal to it, so I get 0,
and when I integrate 0 I get 0.
OK?
So that's why this is 0.
And now where the extended
version of Green's theorem
comes in, is the fact that,
if I look in this region,
F is defined and differentiable.
Right?
F is defined and differentiable
in this entire region
that I've just shaded.
Which is the region between
my circle and my curve C_2.
And what that tells me is that
because this one is 0-- when
I integrate along
this curve it's
0-- the integral along this
curve also has to be 0, right?
That's what you actually
have seen already
when you talked about the
extended version of Green's
theorem.
You can compare the
integral along this curve
to the integral along this
curve because in the region
between them, F is everywhere
defined and differentiable.
So you can apply
Green's theorem there.
It just now has two
boundary components,
instead of in this
case where it just
has one boundary component.
And so since the integral
on this curve is 0,
and the curl of F is 0, and F
is defined and differentiable
everywhere in this
region, that tells you
that the integral on
the curve C_2 is also 0.
Let me say that
one more time, OK?
I'm going to label it in
blue so you can see it.
I'm going to call this
region that's shaded R.
So Green's theorem says
that the double integral
in R of the curl of F
is equal to the integral
around this curve.
And then I come in and I
go around this direction
and I come back out,
and that gives me
the entire integral of the
curl of F on this region.
Right?
The curl of F is 0
everywhere in this region,
so that integral is 0.
And so the sum of the integral
on C_3 minus the integral
on C_2 has to be 0.
Since this one is
0, that one is 0.
So you've seen this before.
I just want to remind you
about where that's coming from.
All right.
So now we have to
do one other thing,
and that's we have to
find a potential function.
OK, so let's talk about how
to find a potential function.
I'm going to do this by one of
the methods we saw in lecture.
have--
I'm in R^2, and I'm going
to start at a certain point
and I'm going to
integrate up to (x_1,
y_1) from this certain point.
And then I'm going to figure out
what the function is that way.
So what I'm going
to do-- again, I'll
write it this way-- I'm going
to figure out f of (x_1, y_1)
by integrating along a
certain curve, F dot dr.
Now I can't do exactly
what I did previously,
because for certain
values of n, I
run into trouble with
integrating F from the origin.
So what I'm going to do
is instead of integrating
from the origin, I'm
going to integrate
from the point (1, 1).
OK?
So I'm going to start
at the point 1 comma 1,
and I'm going to integrate
in the y-direction,
and then I'm going to
integrate in the x-direction.
So this will be my
first curve and this
will be my second curve.
And I will land
at x_1 comma y_1.
So again, this is
one of the strategies
we've seen previously.
This is the idea that
I'm going to integrate
in the y-direction, from y
equals 1 to y equals y_1.
So this will be the point 1
comma y_1, so x is fixed there.
And I'm going to integrate
in the x-direction,
from x equals 1 to x equals
x_1, when y is equal to y_1.
So let's break this down.
And let me remind you, also,
the integral along this curve C
of F dot dr should
be P*dx plus Q*dy.
Right?
And so I'm going to look at what
P*dx is and what Q*dy is on C_1
and on C_2.
All right.
So let's do that.
OK, so I have to remind
myself what P and Q actually
are in order to do this.
So let me write that down,
because this will be helpful:
[P, Q].
P is r to the n, x,
and Q is r to the n, y.
All right?
So that's what we're
dealing with here.
I'm going to come
back to this picture,
and then I'm going to
come back and forth
a little bit at this point.
So if I want to integrate P*dx
plus Q*dy on the curve C_1,
what I need to observe first
is that x is fixed, so dx is 0.
So I'm actually just
going to integrate Q*dy.
All right.
So the first integral
along C_1 is just
a parameterization in y.
So it's the integral
from 0 to y_1
of Q evaluated at x equal 1,
and y going from 1 to y_1.
SPEAKER 1: 1 to y_1.
CHRISTINE BREINER: y
going from 1 to y1.
OK?
Sorry.
Yes. y going from 1 to y_1.
Sorry about that.
Right?
I was avoiding the
origin, so I'd better not
put a 0 down there,
because that's where
I was running into problems.
OK.
So Q is r to the n, y.
So I have to
remember what r is. r
is x squared plus y
squared to the 1/2.
So in this case, Q is-- x
is 1, and then I square it
and I get 1, and then I
have y squared, and then
to the n over 2--
so this is my r
to the n part along the curve
C_1-- and then I multiply by y,
and then I take dy.
So there are a lot
of pieces here,
so let me just make sure we
understand what's happening.
I am interested in
this entire thing,
P*dx plus Q*dy
along the curve C_1.
dx is 0 along that
curve. x is 1.
And y is going from 1 to y_1.
So if I come back over here,
I see I'm only interested
in the Q*dy part.
y is going from 1 to y1.
And then this is r to the
n, when x is 1 and y is y.
And this is the y part.
So this is exactly
Q*dy on the curve C_1.
Now let's look at what
happens on the curve C_2.
So if I come back
over here again,
I want to have P*dx plus
Q*dy on the curve C_2.
Notice y is fixed at
y1 there, so dy is 0.
And so I'm only interested
in the P*dx part.
Everything is going
to be in terms of x.
And let's see if we can
do the same kind of thing.
I'm going to be
integrating from 1 to x_1.
Now r is going to be of the
form x plus y_1 squared,
to the n over 2.
And then-- P has an x here
and not a y-- times x dx.
So again, P is r
to the n times x,
so this is r to the n times
x exactly on the curve C_2.
Because on C_2, y
is fixed at y_1,
so that's why I actually
substituted in a y_1 here.
It's the same reason
I substituted in a 1
here for x, because x was
fixed at 1 on the curve C_1.
So now I have to integrate
these two things.
I'm going to just write down
what you get in both cases,
because it's really
single-variable calculus
at this point in both cases.
The easiest way to do
this, probably, in my mind,
is to do a u-substitution.
Oops, I made a mistake.
This should be an x squared.
I apologize.
This should be an x
squared, because this is
supposed to be a radius, right?
It's x squared plus whatever
y is squared, to the n over 2.
So if you didn't see the squared
here, and you got nervous,
you were correct.
There should be a squared here.
So anyway, I'm going
to go back to what
I was saying previously.
To integrate these things,
the easiest thing to do
is to take what is
inside the parentheses
and set it equal to u, and then
do a u-substitution from there.
So again, I'm not going to
actually do that for you,
but I'm going to tell
you what you get.
Now, there are two
different situations.
And the situations
follow when n is
any integer except negative 2,
and then when n is negative 2.
And the reason is because
when n is negative 2,
this exponent is a minus 1.
So when you integrate, you
end up with a natural log.
So let me just point
out the two things
that you get in each
case, and then we'll
evaluate and see what the
solutions are in each case.
So I'm just going
to, at this point,
write down what I
got, because this is
your single-variable calculus.
OK, so what I got when n
was not equal to minus 2,
you get the following thing.
You get 1 plus y squared,
evaluated at n plus 2,
over 2, over n plus 2.
And this is evaluated
from 1 to y_1.
And then this one you get
a similar thing there,
but now the y_1 is fixed here.
So you get an x squared plus
y_1 squared, to the n plus 2,
over 2, over n plus 2,
evaluated from 1 to x_1.
So here, the y_1
is fixed and it's
the x-values that are
changing, and here
the y-values are changing.
So when n is not equal to 2,
I get exactly this quantity
when I integrate
these two terms.
And so now, let's
see what happens.
OK?
Exactly what happens
is the following.
Notice that when I put in
y_1 here, I get a 1 plus y_1
squared, to the n plus
2 over 2, over n plus 2.
Right?
I'm not going to write it down,
because I'm going to show you
it gets killed off immediately.
Where does it get killed off?
It gets killed off when
I evaluate this one at 1.
OK?
So the upper bound here is the
same as the lower bound here.
When I put in a 1
here, I get 1 plus y_1
squared to the n plus
2 over 2 over n plus 2.
It's a lot of n's and 2's.
But the point is that when
I evaluate this one at y_1
and I evaluate this one at 1,
I get exactly the same thing,
but the signs are opposite
and so they subtract off.
In the final answer, I'm not
going to see this upper bound
and I'm not going to
see this lower bound,
because they're going
to subtract off.
And what I'm actually left
with is just two terms.
And those two terms I'm
going to write up here.
Those two terms are
going to be x_1 squared
plus y_1 squared to the n
plus 2, over 2, over n plus 2.
Minus, 1 plus 1-- which is
just 2-- to the n plus 2,
over 2, over n plus 2.
What it this really?
This is just r to the n plus 2,
over n plus 2, plus a constant.
Because this is just
a constant for any n.
And notice n is not equal
to minus 2-- negative 2.
That was the place we were going
to run into trouble otherwise.
And so when n is not
equal to negative 2--
when you do all
the integration--
you should arrive at this
as your potential function.
OK?
And again, what I
did was I evaluated
to make it simpler on
ourselves so we didn't
have to write everything out.
I noticed that if I evaluate
this at the two bounds,
and evaluate this
at the two bounds,
and I add them together,
that the evaluation here
plus the evaluation here are the
same numerically but opposite
in sign, and so
they subtract off.
And then I just have to evaluate
at this one and this one.
So that's n not
equal to negative 2.
Now let's do the n equal
to negative 2 case.
OK, so now I'm integrating
this exact same thing
in the n equal to
negative 2 case.
And I'll just write down again
what I get by the substitution.
And what I get is
natural log of 1
plus y squared, over 2,
evaluated from 1 to y_1.
Plus, natural log of x squared
plus y_1 squared, over 2,
evaluated from 1 to x_1.
Let me make sure
I have that right.
Yes.
And the same kind
of thing is going
to happen that happened before,
in terms of when I put y_1
in here, and I put 1 in
here, I get the same thing
but with an opposite sign.
Here it's a positive.
It's natural log 1 plus
y_1 squared over 2.
And here it's natural log
1 plus y_1 squared over 2,
but because it's the lower
bound, it's a negative sign.
So whatever I get here and
what I get here subtract off.
And then in the end,
I wind up getting
just the following two terms.
I get x_1 squared plus
y_1 squared over 2,
minus natural log of 2 over 2.
So this term comes from
evaluating this at x_1.
And this term comes
from evaluating this one
at y equal 1.
And if you notice, what is this?
This is exactly natural
log of r plus a constant.
So let me step to the other
side so we can see it clearly.
So this is natural
log of r squared,
but by log rules, that's really
2 times natural log of r,
so it divides by 2 and I'm just
left with natural log of r,
and this is just a constant.
And so my potential
function in that case
is exactly natural log
of r plus a constant.
All right, this
was a long problem,
so I'm just going to remind
us where we came from
and what we were doing.
So let's go back
to the beginning.
So what we did initially, was
we had this vector field F.
It was a radial vector field.
r to the n times x*i plus y*j.
And we wanted to
first show that it
was conservative for
any integer value of n,
and then to find its
potential function.
And obviously we do
it in that order,
because if it's
not conservative,
we're not going to find
a potential function.
In this case, what I observed
first was that the curl of F
was 0.
And so in places where I
had a closed curve that
didn't contain
the origin, I knew
that the integral all
around that closed curve
was 0 just by Green's theorem.
But if I had a closed curve that
contained the origin, because F
is not differentiable for
all the n-values there,
I have to be a little careful.
It's actually even 0, right?
When x is 0 and y is 0, I'm
going to get something 0 there.
So I need to figure out a
way to determine the line
integral on C_2.
Right?
And that was my goal.
For any C_2 that
contains the origin,
how do I figure out F dot dr.
And so I just
compared it to what
I get when I take F
dot dr around a circle.
Because I know that I can
always find a circle bigger,
and then I can say I've
got this region here-- in
between-- on which F
is defined everywhere,
so I can apply Green's
theorem to that inside region.
And I know that the curl of
F on the inside region is 0,
and so the integral on C_2 and
C_3 is going to agree, right?
Because the integral
on C_3 I showed
was 0 just geometrically.
And then the integral
on C_2 then has to be 0.
All right?
And so that was just when you
were using the extended version
of Green's theorem.
And then to find a potential
function, we came over here.
And we had to avoid
the origin because
of the differentiability
problem at the origin.
So we started-- instead
of where we usually start,
which is from (0, 0)-- we
started from the point (1, 1).
And we just determined
the potential function
going from the point (1,
1) to the point (x_1, y_1)
along a curve that went
straight up, so x was fixed,
and then along the curve
that went straight over,
so y was fixed.
And so then we were able to
break up this thing where
I'm integrating over C P*dx plus
Q*dy into two separate pieces,
and each of them was fairly
simple to write down.
So let's look at what they were.
This first one was
where we were moving up.
And there was no dx.
x was just fixed at 1.
And y was going from 1 to y_1.
Right?
And so x is fixed at
1, so I put a 1 there.
And y is going from 1 to y_1.
So I evaluate Q*dy
on that curve.
And then the next one was P*dx
on the curve where I'm moving
straight across.
Right? dy is 0 there, so
I just pick up the P*dx.
And my y-value was
fixed at y_1, and x
was varying from 1 to x_1.
And so then I just had to
be a little bit careful.
I didn't show you exactly
how you integrate,
but using a substitution trick--
single-variable calculus--
shouldn't be too bad
for you at this point.
We distinguished between when
n was not equal to negative 2
and when n was
equal to negative 2.
In the case n not
equal to negative 2,
we determined the
integral, we simplified,
and we got to a place where the
potential function was exactly
equal to r to the n plus 2 over
n plus 2, plus some constant.
Then in the case where n
was equal to negative 2,
when you do the substitution,
you get a different integral.
And in that case, you
get the natural log.
And so again, we just
had the natural log.
We have these
different functions.
We're evaluating the natural log
of these different functions.
We have the bounds.
We simplify everything, and
we get exactly to the place
where you have natural
log of r plus a constant.
And so we found our potential
function in the case n
is equal to negative 2,
and then any other n-value.
So, a very long problem.
I hope you got
something out of it.
And this is where I will stop.